the CBS Morning is pretty sunrise over
New York City there everyone in New York
I'll tell you I lived in Brooklyn for
almost 20 years now is talking about
that Rampage yesterday that wild off the
rails truck uh rental uh that led to
Miles and Miles of a police chase and we
got multiple injured people one dead
um yeah it's not a scary sight yeah
people out there walking around and
hearing about a U-Haul truck but this is
what's so unfortunate this is a world we
live in today I honestly feel no matter
where you are and nothing is safe yeah
but for now we are safe and hope you are
too that's right we welcome you back to
CBS mornings we've got an important
update on the story that we first told
you about two years ago this month
retired army green beret Colonel Paris
Davis is his name is set to receive the
nation's highest combat decoration the
Medal of Honor or as heroism in Vietnam
nearly six decades ago now the award was
delayed after the paperwork mysteriously
vanished twice at the height of the
civil rights moment senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge brought
us his story of Colonel Davis who says
he does believe that race was a factor
in this very long delay she joins us now
from Washington Catherine good morning
to you I remember when you told us this
story two years ago now you have an
update
I do Gail and good morning a team of
volunteers mostly veterans told CBS news
they worked nine years to write this
wrong and late Monday Colonel Davis's
daughter captured the moment her
father's heroism was finally recognized
congratulations to you and it is your
old family the call from the
commander-in-chief ended a nearly six
decade wait for retired Colonel Paris
Davis one of the first black officers in
the Army's Elite Green Berets what does
it mean to you personally to finally be
recognized it gives me a lot of pleasure
and pride in the fact that number when
I'm an American it's Northeast of Saigon
near bangs on Davis will receive the
Medal of Honor for his heroic actions in
1965 at the Battle of bong song hit by a
grenade and gunfire Davis refused to
leave behind two of his wounded troops
Billy wall and Robert Brown as Davis
first recounted to a then upcoming local
TV host Phil Donahue well I told him sir
I'm just not going to leave I still have
an American out there
yeah
and what did he say he told me to uh to
move out and uh
I just disobeyed the order Ron dice is
one of the mission's only survivors
Captain Davis refused and said no I'm
not leaving
uh well
I'm not leaving while I have men on out
of the field
Davis's commanding officer Billy Cole
nominated him for the nation's highest
military decoration the Medal of Honor
but then the records mysteriously
vanished a 1969 military review did not
reveal any file on Davis why do you
think the paperwork was lost I thought
that maybe this was just one of those
racist things that uh
this shouldn't have happened but did
happen and when he got lost the second
time
I was convinced while Davis had more
than a dozen volunteers behind him
historian Douglas Sterner says other
deserving veterans will go unrecognized
the Military Award system is broken
broken not only in the regard of awards
presented but improper preservation of
the history of those men and women this
green binder contains Davis's service
records on Monday we returned it as
promised with the job done there's a
reason for me to say
thank you 58 years later Davis remains
grateful for his army service and the
country he defended America can heal you
if you allow America give it the time to
do so it will do it in spades
Davis told CBS News his family is
working with the president's team to
schedule a formal Medal of Honor
ceremony at the White House Davis's
family is hoping for the spring before
his 84th birthday in May Nate
Catherine thank you so much we
appreciate you and we know that you've
been working on this you broke this
story a couple of years ago and it's
great that once we tell a story in
detail and then the response starts a
ripple effect of fixing what they say is
a broken system yeah it's another
example of Nate it's never too late to
do the right thing yeah and we look
forward to Catherine being at the White
House to cover that sometime before he
turns 84. it's a great story America
often gets it right in the end after we
try all the Alternatives yes yeah so the
American can heal you they'll do it in
Spades yeah so that's glad we're happy
for them